una huelga por el aumento salarial que
detiene el transporte en Alemania
trabajadores de aeropuertos puertos
ferrocarriles autobuses y líneas de
metro atendieron el llamado de las
centrales sindicales verdi y RG para
parar por 24 horas
nos encontramos en negociaciones
colectivas estamos en huelga hoy porque
la inflación nos está golpeando muy
fuerte Los costos de calefacción son
extremos el de la gasolina es extremo
tenemos que pensar cada vez que vamos de
compras
llevamos esto o no necesitamos el dinero
para financiar nuestra vida y por eso
estamos aquí
en su financiero
verde representa alrededor de 2,5
millones de empleados del sector público
y exige Un aumento del 10,5% en los
salarios en tanto de vejez que
representa 230.000 trabajadores en los
ferrocarriles y en las empresas de
autobuses Busca un aumento del 12%, la
ministra del interior de Alemania está a
cargo de las negociaciones
presentamos una buena ahora espero que
los sindicatos se alejen de sus altas
demandas y se reúnan con nosotros en
algún lugar del camino la inflación en
Alemania llegó al 9,3% anual en febrero
según la oficina Federal de estadística
debido a la guerra en Ucrania que hizo
que los precios de los alimentos y la
energía se dispararan lo mismo ocurre en
el resto de Europa que lucha por
contener la inflación en Reino Unido que
llegó a más del 10%, los trabajadores
del sector público y privado han
emprendido jornadas de huelga para
exigir mejores salarios